where's Kelly Clarkson hey guys I'm
David Dover I'm at the Kelly Clarkson
show and today I'm gonna go fish for
some compliments they're making me do
this
have no choice
whoever catches this gets a compliment
from me okay Matt here you go oh let me
just bring it back around hey Natalie
you're a good sport I mean that was
pretty rough with somebody I know now
imagine how it's gonna be with somebody
I don't know and who's like trying to
get work done I feel like I'm about to
learn a lot of people's days here we go
[Music]
I really like your glasses
cool oh I see you already European she's
a running she's coding
no hold on hold on cook she left she's
done okay well nice glasses I'll see you
later
grab it crab
it's just that swedish fish you and I
have to pay you a compliment okay I
sneak we're fishing or come with you
seem like you could kick anybody's ass
like you are the best defense system in
this building
now I'm gonna now I'm going to test that
and make sure you are I'm going to come
in as an attacker and I'm gonna see what
you do stay right there here we go Wow
where's Kelly Clarkson wow the voices
right there what are we like in the
middle of Hollywood okay dude this is so
awkward you guys really screwed me on
this
just grab it's a fish
your wife Sue Smith I forgot you are oh
there's a hook on it um you have very
nice ear piercings you have you have the
best whistle in town and your hats
beautiful grab it grab it
you have very beautiful eyes yes and you
can eat it it's been on the floor a
couple times but you can definitely eat
it Jordan
what's up catch this Jordan you have the
best personality I've only known you for
a little bit but you have a smile that
could brighten up a room did you not
hear my compliment all you care about is
the candy oh no I keep about that too
thank you here's a good sport hey guys
this is fishing for compliments with
david dobrik thank you for having me the
Kelly Clarkson show this is not a direct
representation of how the actual show
will go by I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this